[Musique]
tu je la
brillanceil on va douc comme ça le
[Musique]
bateau
joli si on monte un peu on va voir sa
[Musique]
courbe comment tu veux y aller là tu
veux y aller comment écoute là si on
reste à l'extérieur de son orbite pour
avoir
virage
bon il va rentrer
[Musique]
en
va super doucement là
ouais pas rapide que ça tu vois le BR
c'estre un
truc qu'est-ce qu'il va faire là là il
va rentrer dans la
glace à
fond
ça te va comme cadre ouais mais c'est
pas très beau parce que est dans l'eau
quoi tu veux tu veux le prendre voir ce
qu'il va
faire
pr plus
large plus
large tu prends sur le
plans plus de GR sur la
gauche la
terre moi je pr plus de glace derrière
moins de
mer c'est super beau le graphisme de la
glace est super
beau c'est
magnifique c'est pas terrible je pense
que là faut attendre qu' rentre
dedans dans 7 minutes fa que je change
de
bande va plus à l'arrière va plus
derrière vachement plus derrière
derrière le
bateau la GL
[Musique]
[Rires]
derrière voil c'est
bon c'est joli regarde tuas une grande
vue derrièreas toute la vue derrière
énorme il est bien
rouge c'est quand même beaucoup plus
beau quand il passe la glace ouais c'est
clair il va y aller va y aller là il va
rentrer dans la
glace
comment
tuire
[Musique]
on est pas bon côté pour la
lumièreokut
Cé
là il quit la
[Musique]
glace c'est pour
l'impression
on va se mettre devant devant position
devant devant quand il va arriver'estce